- [Interviewer] Do you see any way out?
You're so young.
- Hm-mm.
I don't see no way out.
I tried and tried.
I feel like, shit, if I
try to leave my daddy,
he'll kill me, so.
One day, I'm gonna wake up.
Just not right now.
I'm just living the fast life.
- [Interviewer] All right, Unique.
Unique, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm from Memphis, Tennessee.
South Memphis, now it's South Memphis,
North Memphis, East Memphis, West Memphis.
But I'm from South
Memphis, the dirty South.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood.
You had both of your parents growing up?
- Well, no.
Well, my dad,
he been in...
I can't talk.
My dad, he been in prison my whole life.
And my mom,
she been in my life off and on.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Why's Mom
been in and out of your life?
- Well, yeah, she had a drug addiction.
And...
- [Interviewer] And Dad
was in prison for what?
- Dope.
- [Interviewer] And you
were raised by who then?
- Well, my mom lost
custody of me at the age...
I was seven.
She lost custody of me to
my aunt, her oldest sister.
She's the baby.
Like I said, she had a drug addiction.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- She used to beat on us.
And so, they took us at a young age.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- It was rough. It was rough.
Because I wanted my mom in my life.
I ain't give two fucks about my daddy
'cause I never met him, so.
But, I wanted my mom to be there.
But you know, she hasn't. She
chose the dope over her kids.
So hey, I don't hate her
for it or nothing like that.
But by her
not being in my life as a child,
and me growing up, I had
to really raise myself.
The streets raised me,
if you really wanna know.
I started whorin' at a young age.
I was 15.
I had to do what I had to
do to get me some money.
I had my first child,
I was 25.
No, I take that back, I was 24.
I had my first daughter.
And I had my son at the age of 28.
And, woo. Shit.
Let me take it back, when I
said the streets raised me,
I didn't have to choose
the street life but, shit,
that's all I knew 'cause
that's all I was around.
You know?
So, it's me growing up, getting beat.
- [Interviewer] How far
did you go to school?
- I made it to the 11 grade. Mm-hm.
Yeah. Okay.
I made it to the 11 grade.
I got kicked out 'cause
I went and did some time
on a aggravated assault.
And I got out
and I start doing Xanax.
I got heavy on Xanax.
I went from Xanax to heroin.
I went from heroin to fentanyl.
And when I couldn't get
what I wanted, shit,
I had to go sell my body
to get what I wanted.
So.
I had my first pimp
at the age of 23.
It's my daughter's father.
Yeah.
I fucked around out here in Memphis
and caught a little prostitution charge.
So, I let the nigger
talk me into going out
of town to Texas.
And you know,
he told me, like,
we was on, a couple type shit,
but when we get out of Memphis, shit,
I ain't got no family up there in Houston.
So the ball game turned.
He made me get out there when
I didn't wanna get out there.
'Cause at first, shit,
I was just, you know,
get out there when I got ready,
when we need the money.
But this was like a everyday thing.
And if I ain't have the money,
I couldn't come in the house.
I was being beat with belts.
Hmm.
I was going to beat out
in my head, pistol whoop.
I had to do shit I didn't want to do.
- [Interviewer] You feel
like you were forced
into that relationship?
- Yes, I was.
But I feel like I was young and dumb.
- [Interviewer] And there's no way out?
- At first, it was no way out.
It was like I was closed in, like I said,
I was doing shit that I
really didn't wanna do.
Robbin', stealing from tricks.
I even got raped.
Tricks who took their money back.
Pimps would kidnap me.
I just been through like so much.
- [Interviewer] And today you're
still working with a pimp?
- Yes I am.
- [Interviewer] And you give
him how much of the money?
- I give him all the money.
Yeah.
'Cause I feel like, growing up
and you ain't got your mother
in your life, or your parents
in your life to, you know,
raise you, to teach you
what's right and what's wrong.
I was looking for love
in the wrong places.
So shit,
I started with fuckin' pimps then.
You know what I'm saying?
I like it.
- [Interviewer] What do you
get out of that arrangement
with the pimp, where you're
giving away all your money?
What do you get in return?
- Well, he take care of me. You know?
I ain't want for nothing.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I ain't want for nothing.
He gets my hair done.
You know, he feed me, clothe
me, house me, all of that.
- [Interviewer] Is he like
your boyfriend as well?
- Yeah.
Well, yeah.
'Cause we've been together
five years, so yeah. (laughs)
I wouldn't call him my
boyfriend, he's my daddy.
- [Interviewer] Mm-hm.
Do you recall your very first
time getting picked up by guy?
- My very first time?
- [Interviewer] Yeah. First trick.
- 15, I was 15-years old. Yeah.
And I thought, you know what I'm saying,
I'm like, shit, this easy,
this easy, quick money.
You know what I'm saying?
I ain't got to ask no more for shit,
I just get out here
and do what I got to do
and support my habit.
Well, he support my habit.
'Cause I give him, I turn
all the cash over to him.
I can't come in unless I got $1,000.
- [Interviewer] How much?
- 1,000.
- [Interviewer] In one
night you'll make 1,000?
- Like I said, I can't
come in if... (laughs)
I got $1,000.
So, you know, it's kind
of fucked up out here.
So, shit, I might be
outside two, three days.
Yep, until I come up with all that money.
And turn it over to Daddy.
- [Interviewer] And
your clients are white?
Black? Hispanic?
- Oh, yes. (chuckles)
I don't know why little
white guys, I love 'em.
Yep. White.
I don't just deal with Black men
because I feel like they full of shit.
White.
What's your kind of people?
- [Interviewer] Mexican. Hispanic.
- Hispanic.
Like white and Hispanic.
I really don't like
dealing with Black guys,
but like Africans, you know.
You like, "What's the
difference between a Black-"
Like a nigger, I ain't got the time.
I really did want them Africans, you know,
from overseas who I know got their loot.
I can smell money from a mile away.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel safer working
with a pimp than being on your own?
- Yes, I do.
- [Interviewer] Does he
provide some security?
- Yes, he do.
And I feel like it might sound crazy,
like I'm paying for security
or something like that.
But, it's nothing wrong with it, I'm safe
and I know he ain't gonna
let nothin' happen to me.
- [Interviewer] But you're
working hard every night.
Are you saving money for your future?
For your... Do you have kids?
- Yes, I have two.
- [Interviewer] And are you raising them?
- No, I'm not.
- [Interviewer] Who's
who's raising your kids?
- My mom.
- [Interviewer] Your mom?
- Well, my aunt, but I call her my mom.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So, they good.
If they need somethin', she calling me.
It's just this life I'm living in,
I don't wanna drag my kids along with me.
So.
- Yeah.
- They stay Cordova with my mom.
- [Interviewer] And are you saving money
for your future or for anything?
- No, I'm not.
- [Interviewer] You're just surviving.
You're still using-
- I'm just living.
- [Interviewer] You're
still using fentanyl?
- Yes, I am.
I've been on fentanyl five years now.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you?
- I'm 31.
- [Interviewer] 31.
Does this life get you
depressed sometimes?
You get down?
- Yes, I get down.
I just had a nervous breakdown
'cause like I feel guilty.
I'm supposed to be in my kid's life.
- [Interviewer] It's gotta be hard.
- Yeah, it's hard.
I can't just break loose from this shit.
I have tried and tried.
Motherfucker take my head,
rammed my head against the wall.
People say to me all the time,
"You're too beautiful to be
going through stuff like this."
But hey, like I said,
I'm looking for love in the wrong places.
- [Interviewer] Do you have hope of one
of your tricks saving you?
- Way of life.
- [Interviewer] And taking
you away from this life?
- Yeah.
Like my regular, like one of my regulars.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- He talks to me all the time.
He know about my daddy and
all of that right there.
My daddy.
So he was like, "You too
beautiful to be going
through this and I'll take care of you."
I be having thoughts,
even crossed my mind several times.
Like...
I give my daddy everything.
And like,
no nothing seems to...
Like, I'm trying to please
you and it was like nothing,
ain't nothing makin' you happy, so.
I have thoughts. Yeah.
This my trick, shit,
he like, "You ain't got
to go through this."
You right, I don't.
But this just the lifestyle I chose.
Sad to say but hey, shit happens.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I mean, this lifestyle, yeah,
you have guys that find you
attractive and pick you up.
So it builds your
self-esteem but ultimately,
I think this probably
destroys your self-esteem more
than anything, right?
It must.
- [Unique] Yes, it does.
It does destroy your self-esteem.
It's a job to me.
It's just I ain't clocking
in and clocking out.
I ain't punching no clock.
It's a job to me.
This how I'm surviving out here.
- [Interviewer] But at some
point, you're selling your soul,
almost, just to survive and
that's gotta be a rough-
- [Unique] Well, I don't look
at it as sellin' my soul,
like I said,
this how I survive, this
how I'm surviving out here.
- [Interviewer] Mm-hm.
Do you see any way out?
You're so young.
- [Unique] Hm-mm.
I don't see no way out.
I have tried and tried.
I feel like shit, if I
try to leave my daddy,
he'll kill me, so.
One day I'm gonna wake
up. Just not right now.
I'm just living the fast life.
And now a day don't go by I
don't think about my kids.
I talk to them daily.
Make sure they good.
- [Interviewer] Is being apart
from your kids the hardest part of this?
- Yes. Oh, yes.
- [Interviewer] Do you
feel like the environment
you grew up in set you up for this-
- Failure
- Yeah.
- Failure.
- [Interviewer] You feel like a failure?
- It's a crazy, crazy world.
But me (sniffs) you know,
I don't give two fucks
how a motherfucker feel about me
or what they say about me.
What really breaks me down, my kids.
But, that's just the lifestyle I live.
Like, "She's a prostitute.
She's stupid as fuck.
She's sellin' her body for a nigger."
This, that and the other.
You bitches on the outside look at me.
A motherfucker don't know
what I've been through
or what I'm going through or none of them.
None of them know if I'm
trying to get away from this.
They just on the outside looking in.
There's plenty, plenty of days
I'm trying to get away from this.
I pack my shit.
This nigger caught me in the
midst of trying to leave him,
then they beat me unconscious type shit.
So, yeah. It's scary as fuck.
It's scary.
Yes, it is.
And I just hate, you know, I
got this monkey on my back,
this gorilla on my back,
and it's hard to shake.
And about me staying in, it's the dope.
It's really the dope.
Yeah.
I tried to get help, you know.
Tried a rehab, about it.
- [Interviewer] Who
introduced you to the drugs?
- My homegirl.
Well, she's not my homegirl no more.
But a girl I used to, fuck,
we high every day and shit like it.
But if I shake this dope,
I'd be a bad motherfucker
'cause I once was and, well, I still is.
But this ain't Unique.
This ain't me at all.
I don't know who this person is.
- [Interviewer] And the
guys that pick you up,
you respect them?
You like them or you just
tolerate them because...
- I just, ooh, if (sighs) it's crazy.
It's eh, I just, you know, deal with them.
And they're like...
I have motherfuckers pick me up
and, you know, I was into
and they ran their trick an hour late.
But it's like, they made me
feel, you know what I'm saying?
Like, I'm somebody.
Not doggin' me, treat me like shit,
like a slut and shit like this,
so these motherfuckers out
here that ain't, you know...
And I'm gonna say made
love, someone made me feel,
you know what I'm saying?
Like I was somebody instead
of treatin' me like shit,
like, you fuckin' slut.
But I'm just doing it,
like I get my money up top.
I never, never take my clothes off.
I ain't gonna suck no dick, nothin',
until they put my money in my hand first.
And I keep a weapon on me, so hey,
you gonna kill me, well,
I'm gonna kill you.
- [Interviewer] Is it hard
for you knowing that everyone
in your life is trying
to take advantage of you?
Your pimp, the tricks?
Everybody in your life
seems to be just looking
to get something from you.
- Yeah.
And I'm the type of person
that would give a motherfucker
the shirt off my back.
But...
I don't know how to say it.
I hate when I'm putting my all into some
and the motherfucker treat me like shit.
Like, you just selfish
and you gonna get what's coming to you.
And once you get what's coming to you,
then God's gonna open up them
doors where I can run free.
You know?
By me saying running free,
being able to get away
from all of this shit.
Like my first pimp, the only
way I got away from him,
that bitch went to jail.
And when he went to
jail and did their time,
woo, I didn't didn't pick
up the phone for him.
I wrote him a letter and
let him know what it was.
"I don't wanna be with you no more.
You get out playing with
me, I'm gonna kill you."
And I meant it.
And I ain't gonna lie,
I get on my knees every night
and pray to the Lord, you know, just...
Mm.
- [Interviewer] Do girls ever
get away from their pimps?
Is there any way to do it other
than unless he goes to jail?
- That's how I feel.
That's the only way I can get away,
if a motherfucker go to jail.
- What was the best time of your life?
- (chuckles) With my
babies, raising my babies.
Taking them to Incredible Pizza
and Little Cici's and Chuck E. Cheese,
Popeyes, Dave and Buster's.
You know, just giving
my kids what I never,
you know what I'm saying?
I hate it.
It's like it's a cycle.
It's like my mama went through this shit.
You know what I'm saying?
My mama got eight kids,
six boys and two girls.
When we got taken away from our mom,
it's like I'm falling in
the same cycle as my mother.
And you know, I pray to the
Lord to change my ways. (crying)
I feel like I'm being
selfish toward my babies.
And I am.
But it's not me.
It's the dope.
And shit, when I ain't got no money,
I got to sell my body to get what I want.
And that's sad.
It's sad but shit, it's life. (sniffs)
- [Interviewer] You ever
been in love before?
- Anyone know it wasn't
no pimp, none of that,
he made me quit, the
whorin' and all of it.
I was in a real relationship.
- [Interviewer] What happened there?
- He ended up getting killed.
(crying) Somebody robbed him
and shot him in the head.
- [Interviewer] I'm so sorry.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What advice
would you give to a young girl
who's considering this life?
- I don't give a fuck what nobody say
about you young ladies, y'all beautiful.
You know?
Try to stay in school,
do the positive shit.
I don't care if
motherfuckers say y'all green
'cause y'all don't drink
or smoke or none of that.
Don't.
If you don't do it, please don't.
Do not turn to drugs 'cause
drugs can have you doing shit
that you never thought
you would do in life.
So hey, (sniffs) with that being said,
say no to drugs and you know,
'cause you beautiful.
And love yourself when nobody else will.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- Um.
(sniffs) Going to jail.
Going jail taught me a lesson.
Taught me a lesson.
So the way I move now,
I move different from the
way I was moving at first.
Like, I move smooth.
Don't nobody really know what I'm doing,
'cause I ain't just putting it out there
like how I was at first.
I ain't putting in no motherfucker face.
I ain't walking the streets no more.
None of that.
I work off the internet. (sniffs)
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you find the things
that your tricks asks you
to do gets a little riskier?
- Well, not really.
- [Interviewer] Without a
condom or anything like that?
- Oh, yes. (laughs)
I need to figure out what to say.
'Cause as long as they payin',
I'm willing to do any and everything
but fuck without a rubber.
That's it.
'Cause I love my mother-fuckin',
I love my life, well, I love my health
and I ain't trying to
catch no motherfuckin' AIDS
or nothing like this.
So I don't give a fuck you
raise the price to $1,000.
I'm not gonna fuck you without a rubber
unless I see some paperwork on you.
And I'll show you some
paperwork on me, well shit,
you can go to the doctor with me,
if you believe the
paperwork fake or anything.
But this one thing, this
the number one rule,
never fuck without a condom.
Yes, sir.
(sniffs) Mm-hm.
- [Interviewer] So tell me
about the tattoo over your brow,
on your forehead.
- It says, "Nick."
- [Interviewer] Who's Nick?
- That's my Daddy. (sniffs)
- [Interviewer] Your pimp?
- Mm-hm.
Yeah.
(laughs) It's stupid,
but I wanted to show him
how much I loved him.
So...
I put his name in my face.
He got mine on his neck.
He wouldn't get it in his face, but,
'cause he said he didn't
want to mess his face up,
but a year later, you get two
tattoos over your eyebrow,
your mama name and your
father, he's deceased.
But you said you'll never
get a tattoo on your face.
- [Interviewer] All right, Unique.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] And I wish you the best
of luck getting out of this life.
- [Unique] Me, too.
I wish myself the best of luck. (sniffs)
Can I have a hug?
Thanks.
Thank you. (sniffs)